>> WELCOME BACK.
THERE IS A MAJOR SCANDAL GOING
ON WITH GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
DEADLY DECISION TO BACK NURSING
HOMES WITH COVID PATIENTS.
INSTEAD OF ASKING HIS BROTHER
ABOUT THE HANDLING, CNN’S CHRIS
CUOMO DECIDED HE WOULD RATHER
JOKE AROUND INSTEAD.
>> THIS IS A NORMAL SWAB, IS IT
TRUE THIS WAS THE SWAMP THE
NURSE WAS USING ON YOU AND THAT
AT FIRST, IT WENT INTO YOUR NOSE
AND DISAPPEARED SO THAT IN
SCALE, THIS WAS THE ACTUAL SWAB
THAT WAS BEING USED TO FIT UP
THAT DOUBLE BARREL SHOTGUN THAT
YOU HAVE MOUNTED ON THE FRONT OF
YOUR PRETTY FACE.
COME ON, WHICH WAS IT?
>> GREG?
>> I LOVE THIS.
HOW BIG IS YOUR BLIND SPOT NOT
TO SEE HOW STUPID THIS IS,
SOMETHING IS MISSING IN INFORMAL
WORLD.
ANY CONCEPT OF SELF-AWARENESS.
CHRIS TOLD EVERYBODY TO
QUARANTINE AND HE BROKE HIS,
THEN HE GOT ALL TICKED OFF FOR
TRYING TO PRESCRIBE DRUGS, THEN
HE ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT HOW TRUMP
IS INDIFFERENT TO SUFFERING AND
HE IS TURNING INTO CARROT TOP
WITH THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK AS
THOUSANDS OF DIED IN REST HOMES.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS AREN’T
FUNNY.
THE REASON WHY THE MEDIA LIE
BACK LIONIZED ANDREW CUOMO,
THESE SKITS AND ROUTINES ON CNN
GAVE THEM THE LET’S WATCH, IT’S
HUMAN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE ANDREW CUOMO ON
SPECIAL REPORT FOR WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF BRET BAIER PULLED OUT
A GIANT SWAB?
THEY WOULD BE CALLING HIM
INDIFFERENT TO DEATH AND
SUFFERING.
CHRIS CUOMO, DON LEMAN, ANDERSON
COOPER, WHAT ARE THEY?
I KNOW WHAT I AM, I KNOW WHAT
TUCKER IS, I KNOW WHAT JESSE IS,
WE ARE COMMENTATORS.
WHAT SHANNON BREAM AND
BRET BAIER IS, THEY ARE
NEWSPEOPLE.
THERE IS NO DISTINCTION ON CNN
OF WHAT THEY ARE.
SO YOU ARE ALLOWED TO PORTRAY
OPINION AND TRACKED AND THEY
DARE TO PASS JUDGMENT ON US AND
THEIR PHONY WORDS WHICH ARE
ABSOLUTELY LAUGHABLE.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, BUT ARE
THEY?
I DON’T KNOW.
>> DANA, A LOT OF THE TIME WHEN
POLITICIANS ACT OUT OF TOUCH AS
GOVERNOR CUOMO DID IN THAT
INTERVIEW IT’S BECAUSE THEY
DON’T FEEL LIKE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS, THEIR INVESTIGATIONS
NOW INTO THE NURSING HOME POLICY
BUT IT JUST SEEMS GIVEN HIS
ANSWERS ON THAT HE DOESN’T CARE
MUCH.
>> HE’S RUNNING HIGH AT AN 80%
APPROVAL RATING RIGHT NOW, I
THINK THAT IS PARTLY BECAUSE I
WAS SAYING IN THE A BLOCK THE
NATIONAL MEDIA REALLY WENT AFTER
THE RED STATE GOVERNORS AND PART
OF THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT WAS
THAT THEIR NUMBERS APPROVAL
RATINGS ARE IN THE TANK.
I THINK ON THE GROUND WILL TURN
THAT AROUND, CONTRAST THAT WITH
GOVERNOR CUOMO WHO I ACTUALLY
ENJOYED HIS PRESS BRIEFING AT
THE BEGINNING, I THOUGHT THE
COMMUNICATION STYLE WAS
INTERESTING.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE BEING AT A
LECTURE.
THEN HOWEVER, I THINK YOU HAVE
TO QUESTION HIS JUDGMENT ABOUT
GOING ON HIS BROTHER SHOW LAST
NIGHT BECAUSE THERE IS A REAL
QUESTION RIGHT NOW THAT PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THE NURSING
HOMES.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT IT
RECENTLY, HE SAID I WAS JUST
FOLLOWING CDC GUIDELINES.
THEY SAID TRUMP CDC GUIDELINES.
THERE WERE OTHER THINGS HE DID
THAT TRUMP DIDN’T DO, HE IS
TRYING TO PASS OFF A REALLY
HORRIBLE, CATASTROPHIC DECISION
ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND GOING ON
HIS BROTHERS SHOW I DON’T THINK
HE KNEW ABOUT THE JOKE CHRIS
CUOMO WAS GOING TO PLAY BUT IT
HAPPENED ENOUGH THAT YOU CAN
WONDER ABOUT THE JUDGMENT OF THE
GUY AND WHY HE HAS AN 80%
APPROVAL RATING.
>> THESE INTERVIEWS ARE ALWAYS
BACK AND JOKING, WHAT WHAT ABOUT
FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST FAMILY
MEMBERS?
>> WHAT YOU HEARD FROM DANA IF
THE GOVERNOR’S RATIONALE, HE
THAT IN FACT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS SAYING THAT THEY
DON’T WANT TO OVERBURDEN A
HOSPITAL, IF IT’S POSSIBLE KEEP
THEM IN THE SENIOR CITIZENS
HOME.
TURNED OUT TO BE A TERRIBLE
DECISION, I THINK EVERYBODY HAS
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
IN TERMS OF THAT SKIT THAT WE
SAW, I THINK YOU’RE RIGHT ON IT.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO A TOUGH
TIME, I DON’T THINK THERE’S MUCH
TO LAUGH ABOUT BUT I DON’T THINK
IN ALL HONESTY THAT ANYBODY IS
GOING TO STICK THAT HUGE SWAB UP
THEIR NOSE, NOBODY IS GOING TO
DO THAT.
BY COMPARISON YOU SEE PEOPLE
HOARDING AND TALKING ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE OR WHATEVER
AFTER THE PRESIDENT SAID HE’S
TAKING THAT, HIGH RISK, NO
PROVEN BENEFIT, I DON’T KNOW WHY
THE PRESIDENT IS PLAYING
MEDICINE MAN.
I DON’T LIKE IT, I THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD TAKE THIS MOMENT
SERIOUSLY.
>> DR. PRESCRIBED THAT TO HIM,
WHAT DID CUOMO USE?
>> THE SEGMENT IS NOT ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, IT’S ABOUT
ANDREW CUOMO HAD A POLICY IN
PLACE THAT REQUIRED OLDER
PATIENTS BE PUT INTO NURSING
HOMES TO THEN SPREAD THE DISEASE
AROUND UNTIL THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
DIED AS A RESULT OF EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
JESSE.
>> THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD
WOULD BE THIS, ANDREW CUOMO THE
GOVERNOR ORDERED 70,000 DOSES OF
IT FOR NEW YORK WEIRD SO IF IT’S
REALLY THAT BAD, WHY WOULD HE
ORDER 70,000?
THE CDC GUIDELINES DID NOT
SUGGEST YOU BRING IN INFECTED
PATIENTS IN THE NURSING HOME,
THIS IS WHAT IT SAID.
IT SAID IF YOU ARE TO DO THAT,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE VIGILANT
TESTING AND A SPACE DESIGNATED
WITHIN THE NURSING HOME TO
QUARANTINE NEW PATIENTS THAT ARE
INFECTED FOR 14 DAYS BEFORE YOU
MIX THEM IN WITH THE REST OF THE
POPULATION.
ANDREW CUOMO DIDN’T DO EITHER OF
THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS WITH THE
INTERVIEW, THIS IS LIKE HOW ALL
OF THE MEDIA INTERVIEWS
DEMOCRATS.
IT’S LIKE INTERVIEWING A FAMILY
MEMBER.
IT’S HONESTLY LIKE A YOUNGER
BROTHER INTERVIEWING AN OLDER
BROTHER.
YOU ARE IN AWE OF THE OLDER
BROTHER, YOU’RE A LITTLE SCARED
OF MAKING THE OLDER BROTHER MATT
BECAUSE HE COULD KICK YOUR.
AND YOU JUST TREAD LIGHTLY, IT’S
THE SAME WAY DEMOCRATS ARE
INTERVIEWED ALL THE TIME, SOME
PRODUCER HAD TO CREATE THOSE
HUGE SWABS.
IT WASN’T JUST LIKE CUOMO HAD
THIS GREAT IDEA, THIS WENT
THROUGH A FEW LEVELS BEFORE IT
GOT ON AIR.
>> THEY WENT TO THE PROPER
DEPARTMENT.
>> THEY CALLED CARROT TOP.